Those are some funky parallels... AAAAA!-
*cut off by intro*
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to "Three Scary Games."
We're gonna be starting off with Sakura
no gaku, the Japanese inspired or
Japanese-made horror game
that's really really good. So, let's see it.
This is a horror game
set, I believe in a Japanese school
where a lot of horror games happen
But we'll see what this one has in store for us now
o .....clock...
I like clock!
It's a Yandere simulator sound, but what is also probably a very common Japanese school sound.
*funiture moving*
A ah
*people talking and laughing*
I like this intro series, it kinda establishes the mood and the theme really well.
Uh oh, don't drift off to sleep! Don't do it.
That's--no, don't drift off!-
*Too late*
That's how they all - oh no- That's how this always starts. Then you're lost in a horrible dream world
AOHHHH no, she did...
Oh no. Oh, no horrible dream world here I come.
Oh my god
*eerie music*
What tha...
What the hell
What... these controls so weird
I can't turn so oh, oh, there we go. Suddenly Oh,
Well, I hate this. Oh
I'm sorry. I meant to - wait I don't, wait,  wait a - Oh, I gotta jump
I just, la de da de- aAAAAgH
I just didn't even give her a chance
Whoa, okay crouch. Yeah, okay, but just blonk my head straight onto that thing
... What is that?
What is that
*said quickly*
Excuse you!
No creepy whispering when I'm about to approach this what might be a mannequin what might be a corpse
Okay lets la de dah de dah to you getting real low on it. What who inspect? Okay. Oh
That's way closer than I wanted to be.
But I didn't do nothing - I didn't stab you
*but i didn't*
I didn't do that!
And where did you al' come from?
All right, okay if you're.. okay
Can I take that knife that seems like it might be good for self-defense at some point at some juncture?
... I don't know what's waiting
for me around the corners but ...
I guess I'll just find out ...
*Demon baby laughter*
Okay ...
I'm a brave boy, but something tells me that's bad.
I got a bad feeling about this guys ...
I just think maybe there's problem happening here in the school, and I'm about to face it
... head-on
Get ready for me to surrender
laying on the line to fight a jump-scare
*yeeiplier*
I knew ... eh hEYYYY
Did you just like did you just like sprint straight through a wall? *huh* HEY!
It could be like right in front of me and I wouldn't know because I'm not facing that direction
Okay, I'll go I'll go in here well, let's do a nude painting of whatever the monster is
Okay. Yo, okay. I
Didn't know that's bad. Hey why that's me. Um, that's not me. I want to be very clear
I got nothing to say about this, this weird circumstance
Okay
All right, we're just gonna let that be
Are you done? Is it still there?... Still there? OkAay... alright... Okie!
I don't like this ...
Fuck this shit fuck this shit. *Tiny gasp* Is that blood or is it just beautiful rose petals?
Fuck this shit, fuck this shiiiiit.
Oh [CENSORD] thIS.
Hi, okay. I don't know what happened. I don't know what I saw
I'm gonna pretend I saw nothing. Oh fuck this.
Oh fuck this, oh fuck this and fuck you.
Fuck this and fuck you.
Okay, I guess we're back to normal  perspective here
*squeaky spoopy sounds*
If someone is stippy stepping behind me and isn't telling me I'm going to be very pissed off
Oh, that's my shadow okay
Oh!
Uh OOOOOh!
Um... UUUUUUM??!
Do um Wha- Uuum uuuuh - Duh-um Wha-ah???
*Confused throat singing intensifies*
That was smart
I wanna point out a very smart game development because it reminded me of the ability to crouch by having to crouch under that
To probably avoid detection there by crouching
Very smart... very- *Gasp*
Not where I wanted to be
Hello
Peekaboo, peekaboo? - Okay can't go in there.
Wait, wait, wait, wait a minute
This is gonna this is who's just gonna show that to me and not this is good
Okay, I guess we're gonna walk towards that
Hi hello fellow student, I'm just...
Ohhh...
Okay, you're fine then?
What are you throwing away?
You need a flower. Okay, so I gotta get a flower?
I think someone shat out a flower in the bathroom back there. Let me- this is not the
This is not the bathroom.
*SNIFF SNUFF* There was a bathroom here.
I've got a flower. The flower. Wanna flower?
You're welcome and then you fade away into nothingness, I'm not sure if that's a good thing. Did I save you?
Those are some funky parallels - EY! I'm gonna RUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUN
Why are you doing this to me? Oh, I wasn't ready for that. I wasn't ready at all
Okay. All right. I was just- I was just minding my own busine- oh shit shit shit shit
Ow what the- I can't- I can only run so fast
I can only- I cAn'T- wHaDdA wAnT mE tO dO?
what do you want me, what do you want from me oh my god
No, no, no no no no no
I was- B-but I was... Aw, I was right there :(
but I was right there- oh shit
oh shit shit shit. I can't- I literal- how do I go? Jump I'm a hippity-hoppity hippity-hohhh
oh, I made it
I made it apparently.
*BIG BREATH*
What the hell?
HUHHHH
Ohhhh
Okay, if I'm piecing this together right, what I just saw was- that was like her dad or something
Or someone she knew, PROBABLY her dad
She had hung herself
But she lived so she was in some weird
Dream world, but then the monster was her dad
So maybe she was abused too, which is even sadder if you really think about it :(
You don't even have to really think about that. Just oh my god
Or maybe it was something about the monster
Following her out of the deep. I don't know. either way, it's bad news. Either way, It's bad news, but that was great
Oh my god
Kenny
Amira
sin(gerine), cos(gerine), Max, Zack,
well doneeee
for as simple as it was; the game, the concepts that you were putting forward, there.
Goddamn good! All of them, all of them, everybody, even at the bottom.
god damn good. That just had this sense of dread
Zack! this sense of dread, Nathan
Yi Lin. Like this... putri, this sense of dread
That was- Wooow
Like I legitimately was terrified there
It was so good it's so short
But so good! The setting, like the theme of it, the mood was set with that intro cinematic. The game was tight
It had super nuance like game- game mechanic, like, teaching. It was w-well done
I think I see something down there now. That was awesome
It was awesome. Oh, it was awesome. All right moving on, but that was awesome
Love that. Everyone play that, it's in the description, everyone play that that's good
terrifying, but good
Welcome to *RUM*  303. Yes. I pronounce *RUM* that way, but that's not the point here. This is a game, a horror game
That's supposed to be about a *RUM*
That's numbered 303. Do you guys understand how much I know about this game before going into it because it's a tremendous amount
So... I don't know what to expect obviously like most of these games. Ooo...Oh
Wait-
(Crows In the Backround)
Okay
Satan: F̸̗̆i̵̟̎x̷̢̏ ̸̣͘T̶͕͂ḥ̸̈i̸͙͘s̷̫̕
HI.  Oh, okay was that you? Was that a demon in my brain?
Oh, that old demon. (〃 ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°〃ゞ
Okay, fix this. You got it, buddy. All right.  *giggle* Let me just put all your blood back in you.
Ju- patch that hole up with these shards of glass that are on the inside of the apartment
Did you jump into my hotel room and just die on my floor or were we in this-?
Okay, if I'm looking at this logically, let's just look around the room first
couch
overturned
TV, dead basically, but a sweet guitar right here.
(Guitar Strums)
Ohhh
(Guitar strums again)
Oh, that's nice, okay, and then a demon in my head telling me to fix this, alright, I don't-
*breath*
there's a lot of things that I don't understand. Either you were standing in this window and
Ooooo. Wow, That's nice cloth physics.
Oh, wow, that's actually real that's not just a premade animation. That's coooool
So someone err, uh, you uh - Larry uh - Bill uh - Ernest. Larry Bill Ernest here, was standing, standing
Proudly in this window, just loving life living life, looking out at that and then a sniper
or a very good knife thrower. But I'm gonna go with sniper, shot him, crashed the window into the apartment
He spun dramatically.
OOOOOOOH!
And then fell and died
And this isn't my fault
This is just random happenstance, from a sniper! A random, random sniper. Okay? All right
(Mumbling) Am I... supposed-
To leave and call the police? Is there a Pho- Is there a phone here that I can use
If I could turn out the lights, close my eyes take a nap
Play guitar... Oh.
DONE. Fixed It. Fixed it good, all done.
Also I'm swaying like I'm drunk. This game is like, Slightly nauseating
Fixed it, Fixed it pretty goo-
Satan Once More: F̸̗̆i̵̟̎x̷̢̏ ̸̣͘T̶͕͂ḥ̸̈i̸͙͘s̷̫̕
Okay, so that guy's, uh- Me.
Me- me guy is in a panic. Oh, hey, how's it going there? It's 3:15 apparently. Okay, is that important? That's what time it is now, so...
Okay. All right fix that, fix that, fix that
Satan: F̸̗̆i̵̟̎x̷̢̏ ̸̣͘T̶͕͂ḥ̸̈i̸͙͘s̷̫̕
dAMN IT! Damn it-
Oh, wait that's Clean- Clean Ox. Okay, that's bleach, so, I can mop up some blood if I'm ready to do that
okay
I don't know what this is trying to do. What's it trying to say?
Oh, wait-
(Eureka Moment) Ahhhh
Satan: Y̴̲̋ò̶̧u̷͝ͅ ̷͓͝K̵̤͒n̶̝͊ŏ̵̬w̷̨͘
I dont-
I don't really know, 100%, if you could just spell it out for me.
If you could not be obscure with "Fix it" and "You know" and oh- "all better" to like nothing
Satan once more: Y̶̖͋e̶̬̓s̴͕̕ ̸̜͌ÿ̶̧o̵̯͋ṷ̶̾ ̶̖̽d̵͍͛o̷̖͋
Yeah, I dunno what I'm doin'.  What's with this ghost here? can I clean up the blood now or do I drag him? Oh shi-
(Knocking) *
Friendly Neighborhood Satan: A̷̟͗w̴̽ͅn̵̲̈́ş̸̉e̶̳̚r̸̪̀ ̶̢̂Ì̶̟t̸̗͆
Maybe I should like cover it up with the sheet. Okay, you know what? I'm gonna answer it. It's- it's fine. All right
Hey neighbor! :) Hey, how you doing there?
Oh. Hi. Oh. (Quietly) What the fuck?
(Confuzzled Mark sounds)
W-wait wait wait
(More confuzzled sounds)
Wait, but-
What, hey, buddy. Hey, w-what are you-? Alright, well if you're just gonna watch... I... uhhh...
(Mark noises)
W-Wait a minute
Larry...
E-even, Even Stephen. Okay, goodbye. See, I gotta go. Sorry. Guh- how do I close?
Uh, close the-, turn the light out- okay
Hey
Buddy, Oh now I can...
Go away!
BEGONE, THOT!
Shh-pshhh I'll spray your eyes out. Let me get that stain out for you. Hey, you shouldn't walk around with ketchup on your shirt
Okay, anyway,
I'll juuust... I'll ju-
I'm good with the door open. Here we go
(Spray Noises??? apparently?)
B-Bad dog bad
Uhhh
Hmmmm... Okay
Ooookay. All right.
Okay, What do we do? What do we do? What do we do what?
Satan Lets Play: T̶̨̀h̷̛̙e̵͍͝ ̵̧͝e̴̳͝n̷̳̐d̵̺̆g̶̺͑ä̴̠m̴͚̊e̴͇͛ ̶͓͘i̸̞͝s̵̢̒ ̶͉̊n̷̨͘ŏ̷̰ẅ̵̘́
The game's ending? Whaaa does that mean?
What do you mean by end game? Huh? The end of the game? End game?
Oooooooooooooooooooooooooh
Satan: R̵̭̆e̵̜͛s̸͕͌e̴̺̕ṫ̷͚
(Gun Shot and/or Thunder)
Oh, what the fuck---ing hell?
Oooookay...
Oh. There we go.
Oh, It was made for a theme of one room. Oh, okay. That's so weird. Wait, what-
Wait, so reset, you mean I have to live that loop? Forever?
What? What does it mean?(x2)
What's the room? Room 303. (You just answered the question)
Wasn't there a movie, like room 1303, where he couldn't leave
Was that kind of like the theme of it like you have to, Oh man, maybe , uh and it just exits. Well that was
*RUM* 303
Not bad
I'm a little confused... I'm a little confuzzled (x2).(High pitch) I'm a little confused.
But not bad, Moving on. This is Indagar, a horror game, of sooome.. Type?
Barky doggy. Julia your daughter is kidnapped in an apartment building "La Hacienda", come if you want to save her,
But I warn you if you show up with someone else or you talk to the police
I will kill her. I see you in that place in an hour. Oh
That's not good
What was my daughter's name again, I've forgotten alread- Julie? Julia! I think? Julia?! Julia...
(mark that's your name u goof)
It's too dark I should find a way to turn on the lights
Good old La Hacienda I don't remember what La Hacienda means
Hacienda: noun
(in Spanish-speaking regions) a large estate or plantation with a dwelling house.
But it sure lives up to the name, whether that is or is not correct. Oh, this seems like one of the
Classic horror games like give me an empty apart building, ?apart building?- apartment building and send me sploring'
Oh good... oH gOoOoD! *~*
Yeah, like most apartment buildings. They just toss bed frames into the- stairwells. Hello. Someone huffing paint in there? Or there's beer cans
Not sure which. Alrigh- well, I haven't found anything to power yet, but I bet I'm gonna find a juuump-
Scare or two
Hello, Julie, Julie- (still not her name, mark.)
Okay, thank you. Thank you for that.
Okay, when did the creepy music kick up?That wasn't supposed to happen, okay
I came a few hours ago, but your wife was not at home. So I entered by force. I took your medals
I will not return them to you until you pay me my money
If this is a recent note, who's living here? Who has a wife here?
Who's raising a family here?
Ohhhh. So these do open. This building is alive.
I doubt that but okay, it's like a Silent Hill house. Is that what you're saying?
I didn't think these are working before but apparently they are working.
Okay
Honey, I went to repair the hole in the wall of the guy from apartment number one
He hides the hole with a bookcase that falls so easily that man is so weird
He stole three metals from a neighbor and kept them in his bedroom, honey
I want to move I'm sick of this place. it's full of crazy people why only people like that live in this building
Why do you live in this building?
Why do you live here? Don't live here. Alright, so someone has a bookshelf that falls easily this one
No, I'll spend in one of the other rooms down here. I mean this one didn't open
Yeah, so it must be this one over here
One of the ones that I passed by on the way in. I probably should have found a way to get power up,
But, hey, here I am, wandering on my own. I said no bookshelf here this one
No, it's a mattress. Alright, so must be out towards the beginning of this area. And if it's not, then I'm stupid.
Lock-ed-ed
So this just doesn't open. I just get to see the beer cans and nothing else?
All right, well, see ya.
Oh, I hate the way those open. Those open...
Badly. What kinda place is this? what kind of place is this? Where's an interior decorator when you need one? this place is in trash.
I meant to say a travesty but then it came out a trash
oh, heyy
Is this the bookshelf that falls away so easily? I bet it is. I bet it-
AHHHHH ヽ(ﾟДﾟ)ﾉ
*spooped breath* （￣□￣；）
Sorry
uH
whAT THE-
*uh mark is ur face ok*
*uncomfortable mark giggling*
wait hang on-
My brain needed a few seconds to process what the hell I ca- I stumbled across
Okay, okay. All right, so he stood on the sink
and he was like
"My pet goldfish is down there somewhere" and dove headfirst down (in between giggles) into the toilet (giggles hehe)
Okay, that's the only reasonable explanation here and there's no other explanation. (mark r u sure)
Oh my God that's so funny.
Okay, three metals, why do I need three metals
Why would I need three medals in what universe would I need three medals?
Well good thing I got that information upstairs first. This place will eat you. Yeah, apparently the toilets too
Oopsie whopsies, right? Why would people live here? Why- why would anybody- there has to be like inspections at some point
Somebody has to ins-ooh...
Sugar the rabbit.
I don't want to sugar the rabbit. This toy belongs to my daughter. She must be here. Okay, whatever you say, brUH
Whatever you say
In case it's the power
Kerchuncles. OH!
Well, that would have been much easier
Well, that would have been much better. Okay. Do I have nothing else to say about sugar the rabbit being here?
Why do I have three medals?
Okay, all right, I'll just wander. I'll just keep wandering, dudes and dudettes. I'll just keep wandering around this weird place.
*toilet flushes*
OH NO, LARRY! (゜ロ゜)
Larry, no..
Oh, shit
(giggling) what the fuck?
He made it down. He was a dreamer
He was a dreamer and he made it down. Finally. I always knew he could do it. I always believed in him. I always believed
and now he- he's swimming with the fishes. (T⌓T)
Just like he always dreamed. Just like he always dreamed. I just find it rather hilarious
Enough silliness back to the seriousness. So there must have been a reason that I needed three medals, right?
So I have to, like, give somebody three medals or give something three medals or takes three medals somewhere. So the guy
who got the medals stolen from them is
was her- oh... ah... oOh
*reads above text in grandiose voice* ヾ(*′○`)ﾟ.+:｡ﾟ☆
Well, I can see why he got upset because it feels like you're just kind of mocking him. All right way fourth
second third
So that's specific, that's there for a reason
Fourth apply
s- oh
Second third apply. Did I do it? *game makes weird noise*
*spooped mark* I did something, I did something, everybody.
*wet noise* Oh shiiiIIIIIIT
Uh oh spaghettios
*disgusted markiplier noises*
Okay, that's just gonna happen now. *reads above text*
Who's this guy, me huh? Figures egotistical as me. No way. Okay, why?
Why why? just wh-
AYYY what the fUCKING WHAt the fuck.
*spooped mark*
Well that scared the p-poopy outta me. Am I dead, is the game done? Is that it? or is there more
That scared the sh- - OH wake up. Wake up
*reads script above in many weird voices*
Why silver? Why can't I be gold? First place? I first place, me best. I'm the best
I'm the best at everything and everything the best, I'm the best
Who are you, your voice seems familiar. Are you my daughter?
Are you my daughter?
There's no time for that, dad. Find the silver amulet before time runs out. It has to be in one of the apartments. Okay?
Alright if you say so
oh shit. Oh
Oh
shit
Alright, well, uh, oh shit
Okay, silver metal, one of the apartments. I'm gonna die. Well, I don't like a ticking clock
Definitely don't like that
Skoosh okay, that's not scooshy no more mister friend, man
isn't there. there's one thing this game has graphically it's kind of fun, like mechanically
It's a little wonky but the music and the ambiance they they did that good that jump-scare was good. That jumpscare got me
That jumpscare got me like goodly. (goodly, mark?)
Building is alive and I'm aware of that, I don't know what to do about it.
okaayyy
You don't need to do that
It's gonna be on the floor, silver amulet CD. Oh wow, it's Guns N Roses, guess it would be up here
Wouldn't it? silver amulet? I mean duh- silver amulet? It could be the second place thing
No, I can't take those. Okay. Well shit, I don't know what, I don't know what it looks like
I don't know what it looks like. I don't know. What am I- I don't know. How am I supposed to know?
Is it just gonna be sitting on something or am I just gonna die horribly? Silver amulet, Guns and Roses, shit, dicks
I'm so dead. Is that it? Nooooo
Ahhh shit. Cock. Ass, I'm dead
Oh, poopy
Oh, pooping my pants.
ohh I don't like that. I don't like oh, I don't like that.
Oh I don't like that
No, I don't like that. I'm dead. I'm dead. Oh, I don't like that.
Oh I don't like that, I don't like it. Woah I hate it
I hate it, oh I hate it
Okay, whatever you're doing don't do it - uh oh
Shit oh it's doing the thing again
ah shit, cock
Ah shit can I huff some glue?
Ah shit that's gonna get me. All right, don't, just do it, just kill me
kill me
Do it do it do it c'mon just do it
just do it. Come on
Oh just do it alrEADY
Eat me like you eat the toilet. Oh just do it. Oh, just do it already
Guess you're not gonna do it
You're gonna do it. I know you're gonna do it
Just do it
HAH Whoa. Hey, whoa, whoa, hi, oh oh oh oh oh
*marki breathh*
All right, I don't know where the Frick this thing would be. All right, let's try again let's look in the rooms very carefully
We're looking for a silver amulet
I don't know what that would be but let's start from the back and work our way forward this apartment.
Anything here silver amulet. I can't open this any more. So that's not there. It's not in the toilet
It's not there. It's not in the curtain okay.
Oh I hate the audio. Not here. It's not down here in these apartments. You almost find it
You almost find it. What does that mean?
There's nothing here
There's nothing it's nothing it's not the silver thing here it's nothing where the hell is it? Ah,
I don't know man. It's not here. Where would a silver amulet be? Well here I go down death again.
All right, no, I'm gonna do something stupid
I'm just gonna turn around and I'm gonna back that ass up into the monster and whenever it gets me
I won't know I won't know. Who knows where is it? Oh
Where is it? Uh-Oh, there's a bad idea. There's the stupidest thing I've ever done. Well leedleedeedleda. Here we go. I don't know
What heckin hell- oh my god Oh Oh, oh
Distress zoom
This is a silver amulet, now what. That was it?
Hmm, all right. Okay. All right. I could have sworn that I saw that before
Or look there before maybe it changes. Maybe it's all random. I have no idea
But the timers still going, is there another one? Oh
Uh...
Okay, uh, I guess I just- Hi, how are you my-
Oh.
*reads text*
Oh, I was a mom! Oh!
*reads text again*
Oh, well I'm not easy to get-to- I'm-I'm not easy. I'm not easy
Period if you know what I mean, ooookay
I
Can't see anything now if we're gonna be fighting in the dark is this why you're not easy to kill?
Oh
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Wait, I'm sorry I'm -indecipherable- I don't know about that *slight screaming*
My god, oh my god
Okay
Worried about it. Oh, what a God, so that was in Indagar. Not bad
I really liked the atmosphere it put together. I really liked the atmosphere
But once again, the game mechanic itself gets really like it's almost like the game mechanic gets put on the back burner
Towards the atmosphere and the horror aspect of it and it's like it could be ooh
It could be so much more if the game was actually fun to play a lot of horror games fall into this trap
They create a great setting the setting is great. The atmosphere is good
It really draws you in you know
The story kind of is like there but it's not it's not perfect
But like the gameplay itself horror games cannot just be walk from A to B
Collect a thing put it in B slot. That can't be all horror games are. At its core
It has to be a game game physically
it has to be a game and it has to have mechanics that come tie into the game and it has to do that this
Was decent it had a great scare it got me good but as a game
Needs a little bit more there and I'm not I'm hoping I'm not being overly critical about it
But it's just like I feel like there could have been some more stuff here. I go into an apartment
I find my daughter. Okay, I get that. What do I need to do? Why am I here?
What am I solving other than finding this mystical metal that protects me?
Makes sense. So either way that's Indagar.
So that was three
Scary games some pretty good stuff there a few flaws on some of them that kept it from being something memorable
but Sakura No Gakkou was
Amazing. So thank you everybody so much for watching
You can find these games in the description below and let me know what you thought down in the comments as well
Thank you everybody so much for watching
If you've got other games that you want me to play in the future write in the comments. Thanks again
And as always, I will see you
in the next video,
Buh byeeee!!!
*horror dubstep music ensues!*